an inspiring story about an explorer who
is making a comeback Against All Odds
his name is Eric Larson world-renowned
polar Adventurer he's known for pushing
himself to the Limit but back in 2021
his limits were tested by a cancer
diagnosis lead National correspondent
David begno shows us his emotional
Journey
Larson is packing for a trip he never
thought he'd make a journey to the North
Pole
it's not the destination that he assumed
Was Out Of Reach he's been to the North
Pole six times already
what's incredible is that he's able to
travel again at all
you see back in 2021 the 51 year old
Larson was diagnosed with colon cancer
he says the doctors told him it was
terminal here in that news
and trying to think about
what those few years would be like with
my family and my young kids
was to say it was difficult is is the
extreme understatement
but the prognosis was wrong the cancer
was survivable though the treatment was
debilitating six rounds of chemotherapy
radiation and 14 inches of his colon
removed what was
your lowest point during the cancer
I mean
how much time do you have there there
are so many low points when I had
surgery to remove the cancerous area of
my colon
I had a very difficult recovery I was on
oxycodone I was in bed I couldn't sleep
and I would
wake up in the middle of night and just
try to walk around the room I could
barely get out of bed it was so much
pain
Larson always had a major advantage on
most people because years of Adventure
taught him how to survive in the
harshest conditions
he is after all one of the world's
leading polar explorers in 2006 he and a
partner did the first ever summer
expedition to the North Pole in 2010 he
became the first person to Journey to
the North Pole the South Pole and Mount
Everest in the same year long day cold
wind I think with the wind chill it was
close to 60 below how many times have
you almost died doing this I've fallen
through the ice I've been stalked by
polar bears I've been in a lot of very
precarious situations over the years and
you get a little bit of a Gallows humor
with that you know in the sense like oh
that was close
let's just keep going
the cancer is what grounded him one of
the chemo drugs diminished what he calls
his superpower the ability to withstand
cold opening the refrigerator to put in
a glass of cool water to my lips and
have intense pins and needles
instantly impact whatever area that coal
was touching
was debilitating and and I live in a
cold environment too so it's not just
about opening the refrigerator but it's
going outside like actually getting to
the chemo treatment was a major obstacle
still though he never lost his passion
for Polar exploration
even though he calls it one of the most
boring Sports what is it about going to
the extreme that really does it for you
what I do is just part of who I am I
don't stop to I don't wake up in the
morning and say oh why am I going to do
this I just do it and so it's just how I
was built what makes it boring though
you're traveling across a big vast white
nothingness oftentimes you know I've
spent days and weeks in conditions where
the visibility is like being on the
inside of a ping pong ball you can't
even see the Horizon but now he's
looking clear across that Horizon back
to Adventure and back to the North Pole
I get the notion of doing this before
you have cancer
but after you survive cancer
why put your body through that again
that's a good question
um and it's one that I'm wrestling with
quite honestly I don't like being away
from my family as much anymore but
to be able to
go back to a place that has been such a
important part of my life
to see it again when I thought I would
never do anything again for me it feels
like the right thing to do this time
he's headed to the North Pole as a guide
to show others what most of us will
never get to experience
you see we can't all relate to his
record-setting life
but we can relate to pain
and
Newfound perspective I'm talking to a
man who set out to explore some of the
far-flung places of the Earth but am I
also looking at a man who's still
searching to find himself yeah yeah yeah
you know I used to go on these trips and
I thought if I could do the hardest
thing for as long as I could I would
have an epiphany where it all came clear
that I would know everything
and what I've realized is that's never
going to happen I'm still looking for
the answers
that I know I'll never find
but the search has value
and the effort has value in my mind and
coming back has value
coming back has value I love that as we
speak he's on his way to the North Pole
headed there now
bravo bravo bravo David to you and Eric
Larson I I loved your question about why
do you go back I would think it's part
of his healing don't you think after
listening to what he had to say
absolutely no doubt but he's so
conflicted being a father and a husband
and a Survivor and does he owe more to
them than he owes to his own Joy so to
speak
it also shows you everybody's going
through something that's right everybody
even as you are projecting this image of
toughness and resilience by doing things
that 99 of us can't do you still find
within yourself as you asked him David
that he's still looking at himself for
the answers yeah thank you David thank
you very much David